sau gần 2 tình trình khai hoa đơn địa từ khởi tạo từ máy tính tiền,
hoa đồng trình đổi ở thành phố Xí Minh còn gặp nhiều khó khăn,
bữa mắc trước tình gình này, ngành thuyết thành phố đã và đăng trình khai đồng bộ
như dẻ pháp hỗ trợ đị hướng giấn, đồng hành với người nội thuê.
Cơ quan thuyết đã phối hợp với các tổ chức cùng cấp dải pháp,
dịch vụ các công ty từ vấn.
Đai li thuê tổ chức tập hấn cho tất cả các dành nghiệp,
hỗ kinh dành tại tất cả các sạp phường,
quẩn vượt các chở trong tâm thương mạng.
Ngành thuyết khủ bộ xí cán bộ,
phối hợp với các nhà quân cấp dải pháp,
dịch vụ các đơn vị từ vấn sẽ đến chức tiếp tưởng ra nghiệp,
hỗ kinh dành tập hấn, hương dẫn khai đặt và vấn hành,
hương dẫn chức tiếp tưởng thảo tác sự dụ phần mềm máy tính tiền,
sức hoa đơn, con cấp cắt tại liệu.
Video hương dẫn mình hỏa giúp người nổ thế có thể tự thảo tác hoặc người thân hỗ trợ dễ dạng.
Các quan thuy cũng thích lập các tụ thương vấn hỗ trợ liệu đồng và đường xây hảo vật đồng,
2 mệt tư trên bình nhằm tiếp nhận và dạp khi thời mọi quân mắc của người nổ thế.